looking at Mary Kish desperately trying
to get the handle of surgeon simulator
hey Mary Kish nurse waters yep oh okay
yes dr. Curie don't have any intern and
we're here for you to help you mangle
the poor heart transplant that you're
about to undertake at rib cage a little
more expediently and get a lung out I
want a single long oh yeah get along out
are u equal to the challenge I hope
you're paying its dr. Kevorkian because
one day you will become the doctor not
as good as you doctor I know oh yeah
look out now just lower it down oh yeah
nice powerful strike tween good follow
through oh yeah there we go we're at
risk this is proper hammer using this is
you really get a lot of force behind it
a lot of torque God just pounding huh
mission over and over whoa no I'm
melodies Bonnie all right you gotta get
some of those ribs free now yes keep
going on that side he's good although
yeah oh yeah now we're in business oh
yeah dr. Kevorkian I think you loosened
up a long process is much more
successful than your last surgery I feel
like every surgery I wear door flip the
patient in the face oh oh my god you
know you could actually kill them by
doing that Wow bail the surgery you know
this is very lifelike it is possible to
fail the surgery I don't know if you
folks at home believe it all right what
do I do now yeah I say you you know
because you had some of that head trauma
just now why do you use the drill and
loosen up a little little hole maybe I
the blood coming out I think that's
reasonable all right you better get that
lung out cuz I'm about to give away some
PlayStation force oh yeah like in like
one minute if we have time we don't have
time for that 30 minutes your time after
three minutes of surgery time I'm gonna
be giving away a playstation 4 and if
you do not have a lung out by then get
you oh my god doc doc oh god oh god oh
god
listen oh no my lost my watch i watch it
it's the second one today oh no I really
like that one sure you have 55 seconds
get move the lawn again Oh long out of
their challenge okay okay what do I need
to get belong out your hair doctor oh oh
oh no that's cool I need to get that
last rib hmm oh no oh it's just sitting
in there oh oh it's right it works
yourself up you have 20 seconds to grab
that long and get it that was perfect i
think that long get your whole fist in
there and grab that long dr. get it get
it about five seconds oh she's got a
hold of it 32 no it's coming oh we're
into overtime you rent you a 10-second
overtime I can feel you cuz you've got
to pull pull just yank it out of there
ah you know is it cuz yes so sorry too
many they're harder than the way stupid
heart that is not a heart heart heart
suppose I'll just yank it yeah I'm a
doctor you're a doctor Mary
congratulations same good job surgeon
simulator now available on PlayStation 4
so that you can make a horrible daughter
situations in your own living room I
can't believe that we saved a life we
saved um he's got one look now in a red
jacket alarming blood loss rate